Each of your faces is
cause enough for celebration.
You’re safe,
you made it back,
you made it home.
We know in the books
to a certain point how
the witchers were created.
The reason we call it Blood Origin
is because we're telling the tale
of the first prototype of a witcher.
This witcher is not the witcher
we know who’s humanlike and,
you know, can take potions
and have powers.
It's 1.0.
But it's the origin
of what enables witchers
to exist in The Witcher world
in Sapkowski’s books.
It’s wonderful and terrifying
at the same time
because you want
to pay homage to the books
and the lore and satisfy
all of those fans.
But also, you want to
create a whole story
that exists, that would
be worthy of a Sapkowski book,
that lives on television
and is self contained.
And getting to build that world
and explain how everything
came to be with The Witcher, it's
just, that's like a golden opportunity,
couldn't get better than that.